in 2004
historic wildfires created a cloak of
smoke
over alaskan forests as the climate has
warmed
such fires have gotten worse in alaska
where spruce trees have fed hungry
flames for thousands of years
large blazes nearly doubled on average
from the 1960s
until 2015. these fires unlock the
soil's carbon stores
and release them into the atmosphere
theoretically
that carbon can lead to long-term
warming and even more fires
yet new research offers a glimmer of
hope it suggests that when spruce trees
die
the trees that replace them leafy birch
and aspen
may curb wildfires and slow carbon
leakage from their habitat
the 2004 fires scorched seven times the
50-year average land area
for alaskan burns this created a vast
natural laboratory for ecologists who
study forests
they knew that deciduous trees such as
birch and aspen
tended to sprout up in the embers of
burned-out coniferous spruces
but they needed to know more about this
transition to understand how the climate
and ecosystem might change
over a long time say a century
from 2005 to 2017
researchers scoured 75 sites where
spruce dominated before the 2004
fires they estimated the total amount of
seedlings from species of spruce
birch and aspen to determine how the
sites transitioned
by 2017 only 28
of the sites returned to spruce
dominance 72
became either a mix of spruce and
deciduous
or deciduous dominated the researchers
measured tree diameters
to estimate the amount of carbon and
nitrogen stored above ground
they also estimated the amount of carbon
and nitrogen trapped in the soil
to do this they compared the depths of
burned
formerly carbon-rich soil layers to
those of new layers
and measured the heights of roots
disturbed by the fires
but they still needed more data to
forecast forest turnover
the researchers panned detailed alaskan
forest fire records
dating to the 1940s and identified burn
sites once dominated by spruce
now in different stages of transition
they traveled to the sites to collect
data
then combine them with data from the
2004 burn sites
the combined data helped them estimate
forest trajectories
over a hundred years this showed forests
that transitioned to birch
and aspen would accumulate carbon four
times faster than forests dominated by
black spruce
most carbon would be in the trees
themselves since deciduous trees gobble
up soil nutrients
as they grow rapidly spruce trees grow
slow and steady leaving a wealth of
organic soil
that readily ignites the live fast die
young approach of aspen and birch
leaves less fuel for wildfires to chew
up and spit out into the atmosphere
as carbon dioxide deciduous trees are
set to dominate the interior alaskan
forests
by the end of this century still unknown
is whether birch and aspen forest will
stave off wildfires
as the region becomes warmer since just
about anything can burn
in very dry hot weather if this forest
turnover
does lead to a less fiery alaskan
landscape
carbon may continue to pool amid the
shady canopy
of the great north's future forests
you